navegar por las calles en canoas
igualsas caseras eso ha provocado la
presencia del ciclón yaku en las costas
del Pacífico Sur generando graves
consecuencias en los habitantes costeros
de Ecuador la secretaría de gestión de
riesgos reportó algunos fallecidos y
miles de familias afectadas por las
intensas lluvias que caen desde el
pasado martes
pensamos que no iba a ser demasiado la
subida de agua
y comenzamos a subir y ya
de madrugada comenzó Todo
comenzó todo el bate Arroyo de mañana el
gobierno de Guillermo lasso anunció el
estado de emergencia en algunas zonas y
el envío de asistencia para los
damnificados aunque los vecinos
reprochan que la ayuda es insuficiente
encerrado cuidando sus cosas no nos
dieron nada Hasta qué no hemos recibido
pero ni siquiera una cebolla que vale 25
centavos el servicio meteorológico
nacional Indicó que el tifón es una
tormenta inusual provocada por el
fenómeno climático el niño que
previamente golpeó el país vecino de
Perú las autoridades temen por las
consecuencias sanitarias que dejen las
inundaciones cuando Ecuador transita Un
aumento de casos de leptospirosis que
superó el medio centenar en lo que va
del año